[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the guardian columnist zoe williams
and the economics correspondent at the
spectator kate andrews there they both
are
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
pictured on the front of the telegraph
victorious 18 year old emma radukanu
once ranked
338th in the world now u.s open champion
from monday she'll be ranked 23rd in the
world after winning her maiden grand
slam title
the headline on the times front page
reflects radukanu's words i'm ready for
anything
the daily mail claims the tennis star is
in line for a 150 million pound fortune
and a new year's honor
a plan for vaccine passports for
nightclubs and crowded events has been
scrapped that's on the front of the
metro
according to the daily mirror one blood
test that can detect more than 50
cancers before symptoms appear is being
trialled by the nhs from tomorrow
the ft reports that the government is
planning to devolve more powers to the
uk's regions and to create more mares
and we're joined tonight by zoe williams
and kate andrews welcome to you both um
let's start with the telegraph and this
is the uh prime minister we're told
they're reporting that he's planning to
to rip up covered restrictions
and says that we have to live with
covert 19.
kate
so this week the prime minister is
expected to ask parliament to renew
parts of the coronavirus act which
includes sweeping emergency powers that
allow the government to shut down
businesses overnight or mandate us back
into our homes that being said uh this
is perhaps going to have a different
tone than we've previously heard from
the prime minister even on freedom day
when he was extremely cautious uh
because while he's going to ask to renew
some of these powers
other things he's hoping to scrap
altogether uh we'll come on to it but
we've now heard that they're actually
not going to push ahead with vaccine
passports for nightclubs and other large
venues they want to make changes to the
travel traffic light system to make it
much easier to travel they want to scrap
a lot of the proposals and try to get
back to normal and i think the reason
for this is twofold the first is that
the data as it stands now and we do know
that these things can change allows them
to do this vaccines work they've been
hugely successful in breaking the link
uh between infection and severe illness
it's not completely severed but
hospitalizations and hospital occupancy
continue to be around the most positive
stage scenarios even slightly lower than
what was originally predicted
and of course the prime minister is
having a tough time on his hands with
his back bench mps while they did vote
through the tax increase to national
insurance to give more money to the nhs
and social care behind the scenes a lot
of his mps are seething they are very
upset about that broken manifesto pledge
and he knows that many of them do not
feel comfortable with the balance at the
moment between individual liberty and
these coveted restrictions so i think
he's going to try to win some back on
side this week by not making them vote
on vaccine passports scrapping that plan
all together and also suggesting that
we're going to try to maintain as much
liberty as possible into the coming
months even in the ottoman winter when
we do know capacity is going to be a
harder thing for the nhs
so do you think that that's what is
about ring winning back some
conservative support because he's faced
such a difficult time
i mean look there are a number of things
to consider here firstly most of the
regulations and laws brought in
regarding public behavior around coving
were not
over that they were brought in under
public health legislation which really
concerned judges because their
their
point was
you know we have the legislation that
could enable these regulations but the
government is using it so they're using
it under existing public health
legislation which is basically doesn't
fall under parliamentary scrutiny so
even though there are always there's
always talk of
parliament rebelling back then rebelling
etc
actually there's very little scope
scrutinize the
that have come out so far
i would argue that johnson is actually
you know personally opposed to
regulations he's personally very
optimistic he's personally opposed to
kind of
any
kind of curtailment of public freedom
and he's also it accomplishes the world
as it could be
it is so
he's probably saying
we've got the vaccine now
there's nothing else we can do therefore
we have to learn to live with it
therefore no more regulations the
problem with that is what we've seen in
the past which is that whenever
infection rates go higher than
the government is comfortable with and
whenever death rates
then the public is comfortable with
all previous there's go window so
right
boris johnson saying
the end of regulations that's learned to
live with life
is for the birds if by the middle of
october
infection rates are anything like they
were this time last year
i would expect that we'd be looking at
at least a fire break half term if not
another lockdown
kate is the prime minister backing
himself in into a corner according to
the telegraph they're saying that
multiple government sources um say that
he's adamant he will not impose another
lockdown but but as zoe says we've no
way of telling how the virus is going to
behave so can he make those assurances
at this stage
well i think so it's completely right to
point out that when we have had
reassurances in the past they have just
gone out the window uh so you know i
don't think anybody out there should be
taking um all of this as if it is
definitely back the government has
gotten better at giving themselves
caveats and giving themselves um some
exceptions to the rule um today uh the
health secretary sasha javed on the bbc
said he didn't anticipate another
lockdown but no health minister in the
world would rule one out so they're
getting slightly better at um caveating
their language um but the difference of
course between those previous peaks and
what we have today are working vaccines
and they want to put their resources
quite rightly into a booster program
hopefully when that is greenlit in the
near future so the most vulnerable can
have a top-up when we have had a surging
infection rate this summer we still saw
that hospitalizations and hospital
occupancy did not go anywhere near where
it did in the first and second peak so
all of us do need to keep an open mind
virus continues to surprise us something
you know tragic could happen with a real
vaccine dodging variant and we could in
theory be back to square one but there's
also a lot of good reason to think that
won't happen and as long as the vaccines
continue to be successful successful in
preventing severe illness i think there
is really good reason to say that the
promises they're going to make now could
hold a lot better than the promises that
they were making when we either didn't
have any working vaccines or we had only
jabbed you know quite literally a
handful of people uh in the uk uh we are
in very different territory uh staying
with the handling of covered 19 the
government's handling of kovind 19.
let's have a look at the metro and this
story here is the one of the vaccine
passports um being ditched by the
government uh initially we were told
that it was under discussion and then an
hour uh later the health secretary sanji
javid has said that they have gone
zoe
well i mean
frankly what we're looking at here i
think is pressure from the nightclub and
the entertainment and the hospitality
industry generally you know they've been
hit from so many sideways
they've got um problem
distribution they've got problems with
staffing the staffing problems are
catastrophic and they've got problems
with
you know the day to
regulations not reflecting and not
taking into account their own forward
panel
um plus the weekly
that young people are actually more
vaccine resistant than older people
which is very surprising
but nevertheless
is the case and if you and further
research showed that if you fired a
vaccine possible it would make those
vaccine
even less likely to take
so
that kind of conservation of effect
meant that this was a very impractical
idea if your aim was to
improve
and it was a very illogical idea if
you're to bring
protection rates down but it wasn't
going to it wasn't a difference on the
ground um and then i think further to
get getting a huge
not even just from the quality industry
but all
the
truth that all industries are put on
them to get back to normal i'm very
unsurprised that they dropped the idea
what surprises me is that they let it
get as far as it got and i wonder
whether there was some kind of play in
that
uh just to say we're having a few
problems with your sound um uh zoe um so
just let you know about that but but
let's um let's pop over to um kate to
get her thoughts on this story as as
well are you surprised that the
government have changed what it seems as
if they they've done a u-turn on vaccine
passports
they've done a lot of u-turns on vacant
passports we were originally told by
cabinet ministers that they would never
be considered that they were
discriminatory then they were coming in
then when boris johnson announced
freedom day he said they were definitely
coming in now we're back to not having
any vaccine passports i'm quite
delighted about where the government
have arrived to now i hope there isn't
another u-turn and what i found
interesting about this whole process is
that we mentioned before that boris
johnson has always been thought to be
wedded to these deeply small liberal
ideas and yet it does seem like his
attitude shifted quite a lot over the
kovac crisis today you had sachit chavez
speaking uh on the andrew mar show on
the bbc uh talking about
he wasn't just making the practical case
against vaccine passports we just heard
some of that from zoe he was also making
an ethical case
against him he said i don't want to be
in a paper carrying country he said that
just because something other countries
are doing something doesn't mean that we
immediately do it we also have to look
at the evidence and this is on the whole
a bad idea and these are the kinds of
arguments we used to hear from the prime
minister before he was prime minister he
is of course in a position to continue
to make those classically liberal
arguments but it seems that he's passed
the torch to sachit chavez so it'll be
interesting to see how that dynamic
continues to play out and but i do think
they were impractical i do think they
were discriminatory and
and they were going to cost the
businesses they were going to affect
probably quite a bit of their profits so
i for one am delighted to see this
policy go the resources should be going
to making sure that people can get
booster shops shots if and when that is
allowed and also to try to commit
resources to educating people who
haven't been vaccinated about why that
is indeed a good idea
shall we
shall we move on to a good news story
however you want to look at it uh one
name radhu kanu she's on the front of
the telegraph on the front of many of
the other papers um but they're quoted
as saying she's been humbled by support
from people like the
queen yes uh who sent her a lovely note
congratulating her on her u.s open win i
have to put my hands up here and say
that i'm no tennis expert and i usually
don't watch it but uh emma radekano has
just i think uh gotten into all of our
hearts uh it has been so fantastic to
see her compete that it was two
teenagers competing in the final was
really something special and inspiring
to people about just how far these young
women had taken themselves at such a
young age and she's broken all kinds of
records the first ever uh qualifier to
reach a grand slam final let alone win
it and the first british woman to bring
home this title since the late 1970s uh
to think that she was just taking her a
levels a few weeks ago and waiting for
her results i mean it's it's genuinely
an incredible story uh one that i think
will warm any heart tennis uh enthusiast
or not absolutely gave us something to
to cheer about uh finally uh thank you
very much for the moment uh zoe's going
to join us um after the break she will
be back fingers crossed thanks a lot for
the minute kate thank you
coming up
after social care child care comes under
the spotlight with parents demanding
government support that's the story in
the guardian tuesday
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight guardian con ms
zoe williams and the economics
correspondent at the spectator kate
andrews welcome back to both of you we
hope you're fixed now zoe and we're
going to test you out
we're going to test you out and come to
you first um let's talk about uh this
story it's it's an emma radacano story
uh slightly different uh take this is
the metro and they're talking about the
fact that nigel farage is perhaps a
hypocrite over his his praise uh he
tweeted saying a global megastar is born
winning the u.s open it's truly
incredible um he's been accused of
hypocrisy because in his um with his hat
on as ex-ukip leader not very favorable
towards
migrants
well it's not just not very favorable
towards migrants he has had an expressly
um he has had a really consistent
campaign against romanians which
considering emma adakanu is half
romanian and half chinese and he has
been really persistently insulting about
romanians and how you wouldn't want to
live next door to one you wouldn't want
to live next door to a romanian family
and he has also pontificated in a in a
kind of inexpert but very transient way
about china as a global force is
it's it's extremely hypocritical of him
to then claim some kind of national
pride
in this woman who is the child of
migrants is herself a migrant you know
she she came to the uk when she was
three years old she is the absolute
poster child for the reason you want
people to be able to move globally
and
express themselves be the best they can
be and make their countries proud she's
a poster child for that and then for him
to claim her as a kind of british
resource when he would have stopped her
coming in because of his fixation with
immigration is quite gawling but you
know bear in mind piers morgan is in
exactly the same boat he was
pontificating also about her
leaving wimbledon because of her
breathlessness which is a completely
legitimate sporting
hurdle you know marcus rashford has said
exactly the same thing sometimes it just
gives out on you and he said and he
echoed john mcenroe and saying she
didn't have the mental toughness to be
the sports person that she thought she
was these these middle-aged men are
actually fixated with making character
assassinations on young women who people
admire and they really do need to have a
word of themselves because their
character assassinations are generally
speaking completely unwarranted and
without foundation well there's no one
going to assassinate the character of
emma radacano she's a complete superstar
and so say all of we
let's have a look at the guardian front
page
kate this is a story about um parents
really wanting that the whole child care
system overhauled simply can't make
ends meet and provisions are very low
yeah this is an exclusive poll in which
the guardian has worked to survey more
than 20 000 working parents and
unsurprisingly the vast majority well
over 95 percent felt that they weren't
being supported enough by government um
to address the issues of child care and
97 said child care was too expensive and
now the oecd says that the uk is some of
the highest child care costs in the
world and this has been true for years
and unfortunately we have a very vicious
cycle of funding right now where
oftentimes those subsidies are topped up
and then healthcare becomes more
expensive and then you have to throw
more money into it and it becomes more
expensive and we have to reassess what
other developed countries who have
excellent quality of child care getting
right when it comes to their costs and a
lot of that actually comes down to the
ratio between children and the child
minders and making that slightly more
flexible but we're in a terrible
situation right now where for a lot of
working parents and let's be honest
honestly it's very often women um who
find that their whole working salary is
simply going to the cost of child care
and and we have this horrible motherhood
gap in which very often and you know
people decide that isn't the right
choice for them but there is no
incentive to go back to work or to work
full-time it just means people can't
actually make the choices that are right
for them they're making it based on
their child care costs and there's
something deeply flawed about that so
the uk has to wrap its head around this
and i'm sure child care
would have been something that would
have gotten a lot more attention over
the past 18 months of course like
thank you so much we have run out of
time i'm afraid kate and joey thank you
we'll see you in the next hour
okay perfect thank you